bonjour nouvelle émission consacrée aux
municipales et nous nous intéressons aux
jeunes et à leur engagement en politique
quatre invités m'ont rejoint sur ce
plateau bonjour à vous Mathieu un Lévy
21 ans vous êtes animateur des jeunes
animateurs fédéral des Jeunes
Socialistes Aymeric angle 19 ans vous
êtes le plus jeune de ce plateau pour
les Jeunes Pop UMP Mathieu Brunet 27 ans
pour la jeunesse communiste et Antonin
grelin 25 ans pour les jeunes démocrates
dont bonjour à vous et ma première
question collégiale un mouvement de
jeunes en politique pourquoi faire allez
Aymeric oui c'est la parole vous êtes le
plus jeune
justement
pourquoi des jeunes en politique
les jeunes en général sont ceux qui vont
prendre les responsabilités de demain
donc pouvoir se former dès aujourd'hui
c'est important
de votre mouvement les jeunes pas parce
que vous vous avez vous pouvez vous
opposer à l'UMP la fédération UMP est-ce
que c'est un vrai
on n'est pas séparé du MP on fait partie
du MP notre objectif c'est de nous
engager sur le terrain de faire passer
nos idées qui sont
qui sont en nous les idées de notre
partie après on peut avoir des idées
différentes on peut les faire passer on
peut avoir un avis différent le faire
savoir et on peut avoir des propositions
et on pourra être écouté si elles sont
intéressantes au mouvement même chose du
côté du Parti socialiste pas tout à fait
en fait parce que du coup le mouvement
les jeunes socialistes c'est plus une
organisation qui a pour but d'être le
relais des aspirations de la jeunesse
auprès des socialistes et encore plus
dans une période où la gauche est au
pouvoir c'est de relayer les aspirations
les revendications des jeunes auprès du
parti et du gouvernement donc on est
dans une dans une une inversion un petit
peu du de ce qu'évoquais Aymeric et ça
implique effectivement que on peut
parfois avoir des accords vis-à-vis du
Parti socialiste y compris vis-à-vis du
gouvernement on est là pour soutenir son
action mais également justement pour
faire remonter ces revendications sur
tout un tas de choses mais sur
l'éducation sur les emplois précaires
etc les mesures que les jeunes attendent
sur ces questions là et donc c'est
véritablement ce travail-là de une voie
en plus de faire écho en travaillant
avec des organisations syndicales de
jeunesse les organisations associatives
d'être le réceptacle de ces
revendications et les transmettre le
relayer jusqu'au gouvernement pour les
jeunes démocrates on a un mouvement ça
se passe
bien déjà on a un mouvement des jeunes
démocrates qui est très proche du
mouvement des aînés qui a surtout
vocation accueillir les nouveaux
adhérents et à les former d'abord parce
qu'on a forcément des jeunes qui forment
les nouveaux adhérents avec le support
bien sûr des fernations des aînés mais
on est intégré totalement c'est on est à
la fois un laboratoire d'idées puis un
laboratoire de formation laboratoire
d'idées parce que on peut porter les
sujets de la jeunesse qui sont parfois
plus innovants plus
à la pointe de ce que souhaite les
jeunes que que ce qu'apporterait les
fédérations
qui peuvent être prises par François
Béraud lui-même est déjà des fois
controversé au sein de son mouvement sur
des décisions en fait on les jeunes ont
des présences plutôt sur sur des
conseils municipaux sur des sur leurs
propres responsabilités au modèle en
défend les responsabilités individuelles
donc c'est les c'est les jeunes qui
eux-mêmes défendent leurs propres
positions on n'a pas ce genre de rapport
de force
parce que il y a pas de rapport de force
au sein des Jeunes Démocrates et du
modèle est-ce que chez vous il y a des
rapports
pareil pour les jeunes qui ont envie de
s'engager en politique pour changer pour
changer les choses pour changer la vie
au quotidien et du coup on la conçoit
comme une organisation qu'elle a pour
permettre aux jeunes d'exprimer leurs
colères de les de les organiser d'avoir
le temps de la réflexion collective le
temps de l'expression le temps de
l'expression collective
et du coup pour pouvoir dépasser aussi
les cadres un petit peu contraints du
débat politique tel qu'on tel que les
jeunes peuvent le vivre aujourd'hui et
donc une parole des portes d'entrée un
peu nouvelles c'est ça
c'est ça une organisation faite pareil
pour les jeunes et que du coup être des
discours spécifiques à porter sur la
jeunesse dans la situation telle qu'on
la vit aujourd'hui
de la Fédération des Jeunes Socialistes
alors c'est un peu mode même mode de
fonctionnement vous apportez une parole
d'une certaine manière oui une
organisation faite par les jeunes qui a
une spécificité pas juste une
organisation jeune d'un parti d'un parti
politique alors quand on voit les
sondages on a souvent le sentiment que
les jeunes s'engagent pas forcément en
politique alors vous vous êtes les
témoins de votre notamment de votre
engagement Mathieu je vais rester avec
vous parce que vous avez 27 ans vous
êtes le plus âgé de ce plateau si on
peut dire et vous êtes engagé depuis
pratiquement 10 ans vous avez 17 ans
quand vous êtes engagés est-ce que vous
diriez que ce scrutin des municipal
c'est le scrutin pareil par existence
par essence pour les jeunes pour se
faire entendre
il a la particularité ce scrutin d'être
en fait enfin l'élection l'élection
municipale c'est celle qui est
identifiée par les citoyens comme la
plus proche des gens les gens
connaissent leur mère la ville dans
laquelle on vit dans laquelle on a
grandi ou dans laquelle on a étudié
c'est quelque chose de c'est quelque
chose de concret
il y a donc des mots effectivement des
moments de d'entrer en politique qui
sont qui sont super intéressants sur
voilà les MJC sur l'accès à la culture
locale sur des questions de formation
sur les questions de transport aussi les
villes ont des choses à faire jouer une
particulièrement sur la sur l'accès à la
culture et il y a effectivement des
choses des choses à jouer parce que
c'est le lieu de vie
le plus le plus local en 2008 sur une
liste aux Mureaux est-ce que vous serez
à nouveau sur une liste aux prochaines
municipales ce que vous en avez envie en
tout cas
après la démarche de l'AJC c'est celle
de tenir de tenir ses campagnes dans la
période qui est celle là droite va être
des étrangers droit au travail des
jeunes et du coup après dans la
construction de ces campagnes dans
l'engagement politique de cette période
où il y a besoin d'aller à la bataille
on va construire avec le Front de gauche
parce qu'on est parti prenante de la
démarche on va construire effectivement
avec le Front de gauche et si le Front
de gauche et le Parti communiste
dans cette construction commune
vous y serez a envie effectivement en
Israël et le mouvement jeune communiste
de France ne présente pas de candidat en
tant que tel on n'est pas en contact
vous serez candidat sur une liste à
Viroflay mature un Lévis aussi peut-être
à Saint-Cyr-l'École en tout cas si vous
êtes vous êtes prêts
donc au niveau de ces municipal est-ce
que c'est vraiment un moment très
important pour les jeunes pour
s'exprimer c'est aussi peut-être
l'occasion pour des jeunes de s'engager
en politique c'est plus simple sur un
scrutin de liste par exemple que sur un
scrut une nominal comme peuvent être
législatives par exemple c'est une
élection qui est extrêmement importante
pour les jeunes parce que c'est d'abord
le
l'élection de la proximité où on a
vraiment une possibilité d'agir sur ce
qui se passe autour de nous les jeunes
peuvent se faire élire ce qui est
beaucoup plus difficile pour des
élections plus importantes enfin de
niveau plus élevé et les municipales
c'est les élections où les jeunes ont
des postes où ils peuvent prendre des
responsabilités ils peuvent s'engager
par eux-mêmes vous disiez tout à l'heure
le langagement des jeunes en politique
est pas forcément évident je pense que
d'abord il y a le fait que pendant les
études on n'est pas on peut pas
forcément s'engager sur du long terme un
endroit malgré tous les jeunes
s'engagent beaucoup dans les
associations ils peuvent aussi s'engager
le mouvement étudiants mais bon c'est
pas toujours s'engager dans un parti ça
peut être d'autres d'autres engagements
au niveau de l'université ou ce genre de
choses
donc évidemment à titre là on investira
pleinement la campagne des élections
municipales que l'on soit sur les listes
ou pas après tout peu importe l'objectif
ça sera effectivement que euh
politique s'orienter vers les jeunes et
évidemment vers la transformation
sociale j'ai aussi envie de vous
demander si vous n'avez pas des fois un
peu de doute c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup de en ce moment on parle du
principe de moralisation de la vie
politique on a vu la faire Cahuzac et
aussi ce député Henri Guaino qui monte
au créneau contre le gentil donc des
fois il peut y avoir un peu une remise
en cause de la vie politique et comment
on garde confiance alors Aymeric ou qui
avait 19 ans qui militait depuis déjà
quatre ans comment on garde confiance
dans la politique comment on a pas de
est-ce que vous avez des doutes parfois
est-ce que j'ai des doutes non pas
particulièrement je pense vraiment que
ce n'est pas parce que une seule
personne fait une erreur ou un écart que
l'ensemble de la classe politique qui
est corrompue ou quoi que ce soit je
pense vraiment que c'est l'engagement
qui prime mais
et
l'écart de Jérôme Cahuzac qui est certes
dommage pour la République
ne doit pas se retrouver comme un cas
général ou chaque député c'est ce que
vous pensez aussi rapidement chacun moi
je crois qu'il faut les laisser la
morale au moralisateur et au
prédicateurs la vraie question autour de
la moralisation on pourra reprendre la
moralisation du capitalisme de Sarkozy
au début de la crise en 2009 c'est une
course c'est une course à l'échec la
vraie question c'est à quoi sert l'élu
est-ce que du coup on s'engage sur des
valeurs ou du coup on fait de la
politique sur sur des tweets ou des
trucs comme ça et y compris on assiste à
des choses qui sont à la limite de
l'incitation à la haine Russell je pense
à Vialat le député maire dans le Var qui
fait le lien entre entre casseurs entre
esclavage
jamais de doute
des doutes des ans de militant
on remet à jour nos modes d'engagement
pour qu'on puisse coller pour qu'on
puisse coller à l'actualité pour qu'on
puisse adapter nos
campagnes à la réalité et qu'on puisse
du coup sans faire des leviers pour
transformer pour transformer la société
on va poursuivre cet entretien
wilfriedrichy va nous rejoindre dans
quelques instants on va évoquer d'autres
thèmes d'actualité l'emploi et la
réforme des retraites vous êtes tout
jeune mais la retraite il faut y penser
et d'abord on va aller du côté de
Versailles puisque Marine Le Pen est
venu récemment dans les Yvelines pour
soutenir les militants et les tistes de
lys pardon aux municipales
Marine Le Pen poursuit son tour de
France des fédérations départementales
une halte ce mercredi soir à Versailles
pour soutenir les candidats aux
municipales avec des espoirs dans les
Yvelines bien sûr c'est une fédération
qui a repris un très grand dynamisme qui
marche très bien qui est une des belles
fédérations d'Île-de-France car sur fond
de crise de réforme des retraites doses
du chômage et d'insécurité le Front
National est plus que jamais sur de
séduire les électeurs l'ambiance a
changé assure les représentants ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que même des
gens qui ont de sollicite pas Madame des
gens qui ne sont pas adhérents viennent
nous voir et ça franchement on doit
beaucoup Amarine parce que elle a réussi
quand même à ce que des gens puissent
comme ça venir vers nous sans avoir peur
dans leur propre commune d'afficher
leurs couleurs dans les Yvelines 10 tête
de liste sont connues et à Versailles le
candidat se voit déjà au second tour je
pense que le Front national va rentrer
en force au conseil municipal de
Versailles de par le fait